hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream
q and a section sorry about the
shenanigans with the timer up front
we briefly slipped off our timeline
landed on one that was pretty freaking
great and then
suddenly zap we were back here right
here right here
this one does have cats though so many
cats we're always pleased to provide
cats for those of you who enjoy them and
for those of you who don't why not
seriously what's wrong with you dog
people well we also have a dog
she is looking at the cats wondering why
she doesn't get treats
she'll get treats sooner or later yeah
all right we are going to start with
some questions from
episode 42 and then move into
this today's today's questions all right
uh the first one is just a comment
uh that had a cut that came in a couple
times
please see wynton marcellus is the ever
funky lowdown
apparently he was on bill maher i don't
i don't know it but it came in enough
times that i thought
i'd share it i am so curious as to why
this would come up multiple times yeah
it's got to be more than just a cool
song yeah i would think so all right
it's a great title
yep indeed uh the next question that i
had pulled from
last episode uh actually got repeated
today
so uh believe it or not uh md done i had
already
decided that we were going to answer
your question which last time read
i know they're important but why do bats
have to be so f and creepy
all the time oh boy
um yeah they they ain't creepy here's
the thing
you encounter bats at a time
when you're feeling a sense of
foreboding and creepiness because
night is falling or something like that
and
um when you get to know bats they really
aren't this way
um for one thing you probably don't
realize that there are something like a
thousand species of bats
on earth that's a large number of
different kinds of creatures that's
almost a quarter of
mammal species and they are tremendously
diverse
some of them are even quite beautiful
quite easy to relate to you've probably
seen flying foxes from
the old world those are fruit bats and
flower bats from the old world that look
like dogs
except hung upside down
yeah there's one can you put this on the
screen
yeah that's a terrapode now this is a
non-echolocating
bat in a family it includes some very
large creatures
but anyway bats i worked on were new
world fruit bats which are a little
strange looking is that could you put up
the picture i gave you
all right so here's some tent making
bats i took this picture
the last time heather and i were in the
amazon
um these guys are tiny little bats like
10 grams
a piece and you see they have fleshy
little appendages on their noses those
appendages do not have any bone in them
those appendages when you hold one of
these animals in your hand the
flat the nose leaf jitters back and
forth very uh remarkably
if you watch bat mothers tend to their
offspring it's
absolutely adorable right they're very
they have tiny numbers of offspring
mothers will fly around with a bat
attached to them
under their wing and then when the
animal is large enough that the mother
can't fly with it at the point that the
baby is more than 25 the size of the
mother they'll leave it in the roost
and they'll come back and they'll
ferociously clean its wings of parasites
and things like this
and uh and feed the the offspring anyway
they really are in mammals a mother's
care for her baby
is universal it is universal even in
centurio cynics
even oh you would bring up the i did
yeah zach would you show
scenterio cenex the wrinkle-faced bat uh
you've got it upside down
yes indeed um uh google returned it to
me upside down yeah oh really
yeah surprisingly the dark as it were
um so this animal uh this is another
phyllostamatid right
uh phyllostomid yes it's a final stomach
bat
um fruit eater and this animal eats
fruits that it can't
carry so it kind of buries its face in a
large
fruit on the tree which is probably why
selection has
purged the face of fur
when this animal sleeps it pulls a
flap of skin over its face and that flap
of skin has two
light spots in it so it can see shadows
through it
um it's not a handsome creature no um
no it even hides from itself it even
hides from itself
um but anyway i guess my point would be
this
um i mean you started i shared a picture
of flying fox you started by saying the
flying foxes are quite beautiful
um but no one living in the new world
ever sees those like they're not here
and you know
one of the misnomers is that there's old
world and new world bats
um and all the all the so-called old
world bats
are these beautiful flying foxes no
these these uh
these uh microbats
these echolocators are actually the vast
majority of bats throughout the world
and there are only a few
of the megabats um that are they're
quite
beautiful actually but unless you're in
the old world which includes australia
and um
africa and some parts of south asia
you'll never run into them yeah and even
so you know what you might run into is
actually we did on one of our first
trips to madagascar is
um a tree full of them just beginning to
wake up at night and you might
effectively startle yourself so much
that you embarrass yourself in front of
the local people
as we did never happened never happened
um but anyway
the thing is you don't have good access
to bats in general so you don't realize
that all of the characteristics that
make a creature endearing
you know look you probably think rodents
are kind of creepy and gross
right but then you realize squirrels are
rodents and squirrels are actually
tremendously engaging highly intelligent
um fun to watch and i find bats are kind
of like this too
there are some species that are creepy i
mean vampire bats now that's a creepy
animal and it smells creepy
but a fishing bat is an amazing
animal that can basically detect the
presence of fish
when fish come up to the surface to feed
they make a ripple
this bat can detect the ripple with an
echolocation call
and it swoops in over the water and
gaffs the fish
this is an amazing remarkable thing and
it's not creepy
it's fascinating when you watch a fruit
bat cleaning its young it's
endearing and so anyway i think a lot of
this has to do with the fact that a
humans are sort of predisposed to be
creeped out by
things in the dark and b that our
encounter with bats is often
um at a distance and sort of the jarring
discovery that oh that's not a bird
but the close encounters with these
things reveal that they are
really interesting um
mammals that if flipped right side up
and in the day
you would feel very differently about
them all right next question
are humans the only species that use
dopamine and does evolutionary biology
have anything interesting to say about
dopamine and social media
i meant to actually look this up to make
sure but i believe
that dopamine dopamine is at least as
old as vertebrates and it may actually
extend far far older than that
into the into the history of animals
so certainly certainly it's not just
humans or primates or mammals um it's at
least all vertebrates and
maybe far far alert than that right but
what that means and what that doesn't
mean
um is a little bit tougher
puzzled so um you get into this with
actually peterson and his
uh the reason that he is associated with
lobsters is that his point
is that serotonin i believe is
associated with uh
dominance hierarchies and it goes back
to our branching point with the
crustaceans
um and so his at least that's where it
goes back right so his point is this
isn't a human thing get over it right
this is a really really ancient thing
and his point is right about this
now the problem though if you want to
challenge it
is these molecules are
part of an agreement right a physical
agreement
the molecule be it a hormone
or a pheromone is a molecule built to
trigger a receptor when it hits it
because it has the right
shape and the right configuration of
charges on its surface
it could be anything right so you could
take
dopamine and you could engineer a system
in which dopamine did serotonin's job
and serotonin did dopamine's job
and it would work just as well because
the point is well it's actually like
this
when you hit yourself in the eye and you
see light why did you see light there's
no light
right you see light because those are
light receptors and you've triggered
them with pressure
but they detect it as light because they
send the message to the part of the
brain that detects light
and so the point is what it's wired to
is what dictates what it does not the
shape of the molecule the molecule is
totally arbitrary so so in the case of
for instance peterson's lobsters
um serotonin is both h is ancient
and hierarchies are ancient and the link
between those two
also turns out to be ancient but that
third thing isn't inherently true just
because the first two things are true
right it doesn't have to be true right
one of two things
it is in this case right but right it
could be that
um the molecule was associated with
hierarchies and lobsters and is
associated in
with hierarchies in us but that wasn't a
continuous process
or it can be that it was continuous but
it doesn't
it doesn't really matter in case of
dopamine it will serve a
very similar function for many many
ancestors
right so uh back probably through all of
mammal's dope i mean it's going to play
a reward
uh role does it play that reward role
you know in vertebrates deeper than that
i don't know
i i would guess it probably does yeah
that'd be my guess too but i don't know
but it doesn't really matter yes very
ancient not not about humans in the
slightest
yeah uh so the second part of that
question which we're probably spending
too
long on these early questions is does
evolutionary biology have anything
interesting to say about dopamine and
social media
um well yeah
obviously a mechanism
that causes you to release dopamine
captures your attention
and tends to get you focused on it
um so for example you know
a would-be lover
who tantalizes you such that you feel
rewarded for being in their presence
right captures your attention and makes
it harder for somebody else to get your
attention
so that can be a game now in that case
it's a natural game and you may have an
interest in
playing along in the case of the
social media platforms they have
gamified
their war with each other in order to
keep you on site
they have figured out how to trigger
rewards that shouldn't be triggered in
you so
it may be that you should go out and do
some exercise
and go encounter something real but
facebook
is tricking you into staying on facebook
by making you feel as if you're doing
something that's good for you
and it causes self-harm and so anyway
tristan harris would be the go-to guy on
this question
we should have him on the podcast oh
absolutely for sure but
yes so it does have something to say
mostly what it says is that this
endogenous system is being gamed for
somebody else's advantage
that's right and final question from
episode 42
what's the explanation for
totalitarianism i don't think the woke
left sees themselves a totalitarian but
does that mean does that mean it comes
naturally
all right i would say the explanation
for totalitarianism
is in some ways just almost too obvious
which is that
you can do very good things for you if
you have total power over people
right and so the ways for people to
discover that it is the right thing for
them to do to install a system that just
so happens to put them in charge
of what you do um we should that's an
evergreen discovery
and in both senses of the term i guess
but uh yes it is and the whole point
for the rest of us is to figure out hey
how can we stabilize a system
that does good for people in some way
that's fairly distributed and resists
falling into totalitarianism
and what we are facing now is the pull
of totalitarianism
is uh we are in a tractor beam and we
are being pulled towards something
stupid and it could be one of a couple
different kinds
but it hardly matters because what we
have is better than that
we should we should fix what we have so
we don't fall into the black hole
yeah and i mean there's this this is
always a tension between
what has been and what could be which is
sometimes understood as
conservative versus liberal as the past
versus the future
as orthodoxy versus heterodoxy
but the fact is that we need both and uh
the totalitarians
always come pretending to be
well i don't know about always these
now are pretending to be about the
future and so
um come close in the language of of the
left of course this is
um it has actually nothing to do with
what does this look like the future or
the past
it's will this look like it's good for
me or good for
everyone oh it's gonna it's gonna be
good for me that's why that's
actually what it ends up at and are some
people actually confused do some people
not
see that who are engaged in this
movement probably but it doesn't matter
because it's still what's what's going
to be the effect
okay this came the next question before
we get into questions from episode 43
came
from the discord server well where they
um
people on the discord server vote on a
question one question
every week that they want answered here
the unscientific issues plaguing
academia and public discourse are not
new
pinker notes similar conflicts between
eo wilson trivers
dawkins and radical science for instance
than specified here but gold and low
intent and the spanish of san marco
can we solve the problem of
ideologically driven scholarship or
merely mitigate its effects
what selective pressures are necessary
to create a system that rewards
objectivity
um sweet question right
yeah i mean i i think actually this is
simple to articulate what it needs to be
difficult to implement but if you think
back
to the good old days which were not so
good but the good old days
in which uh science discovered things
regularly of high value without
so much garbage they actually
existed in an era in which
people's incentives were aligned now i'm
not advocating for a science in which
only the rich can participate but when
the rich participate in science
they are in some sense immune from the
short-term
financial corruptions that dog others
right so if you had gentlemen scientists
they were free to say heterodox things
and if it
you know didn't interrupt their ability
to earn because basically
wealth was the substitute for earning
so the point is if you want the system
to work well
which is a little bit like what tenure
is supposed to um
create yep tenure is supposed to and it
doesn't
supposed to replicate the aristocracy
the protections that the aristocracy
have
right and let's just say the reason
tenure doesn't work in my opinion or at
least one of them
is that the rigors of what you have to
go through to get
tenure are mutually exclusive with the
instincts that will cause you to use
tenure to good effect right so they
ensure that you're not up to anything
heterodox stay in line stay in line
stay in line stay alive okay you're free
you have anything to say right no
actually it turns out not and so you can
think of this as the same thing
as our electoral politics right it's
like
let's see how good you are at this
corruption game you know
and then you achieve office and it's
like well
you know act on behalf of the public um
well not bloody likely you know you've
basically
um you know tested people's mathematical
ability
with a pole vaulting competition or
something
but uh if you want this system to work
you have to align people's incentives
with being right
in the long term that's one of the
things that should
somehow reward you so if you're after
legacy if you want to be remembered
forever
being really really really right is the
way to do it right the other thing
not just being really really really
right but being really really really
early we want you really right and
really early that's the gold standard
now the problem that we have which i
have
decried many times is that we honor
things
that are a little bit early right stuff
that's too early
oh we absolutely murder that stuff we
murder that stuff and then we never
rehabilitate it we don't go back and say
by the way you know who turned out to be
right this person who was 200 years
ahead of darwin right
very occasionally those stories do get
do get resurrected and i can't come up
with any of those examples right now but
um
in part the problem is that it's you
know by virtue of it being that early
it's unrecognizable by almost everyone
so some of those people
have you know simply a vested interest
in keeping the status quo of course and
so would not see it even if they could
but most people simply cannot see that
which comes so early that none of the
contacts yet exists
right but our system of peer review
is the biggest obstacle to this working
right because peer review
manages to keep all of the really
heterodox
stuff out as a matter of quality control
which means at the point that somebody
turns out to have been way ahead of
their time there's likely to be very
little evidence of it and certainly it's
not evidence that you have to deal with
well it's not just peer review of course
it's the um
the market incentives by universities
and to have faculty who bring in large
grants
because the large grants get 28 to
75-ish percent
taken off the top as overhead to run the
universities
and so you want scientists if you're a
university who's bringing in large
grants from if you're in the united
states probably nsf nih
dod whatever it is and um
that means that big science that is big
expensive science is that which is
um is preferred is selected for and so
sort of you know the kind of math that
you could do on a chalkboard or the kind
of research that you could do in the
field with a machete and duct tape and
paracord and a plane ticket
not really encouraged by big
universities because they don't bring in
the grants that allow the overhead to
run the libraries and clean the
sidewalks and such
what i'm imagining many of the people we
have known
yes uh taking the method section that
you just sketched out there and
duct taping a plane ticket to
a machete or i don't know what they
would be doing but um
all right so the problem
though is we have to um the incentives
don't allow the people
into the system for the reason you just
described because of the grant overhead
peer review prevents the lodging it's
very hard to
short the field uh to the
the school of thought that owns the
field and say actually they've got it
wrong
because it won't be registered anywhere
it'll be treated as kook stuff and then
you won't be able to resurrect it
even the um the pre-print servers which
in theory should correct for this you
have to have
a certain credential in order to even
use them so they bar
people who are outside who should be
able to lodge their shorting of the
field
uh just as uh as prominently well and
this this is one of the few exciting
things
about early covet pandemic actually as
we talked about in our early episodes
right that the pre-print servers were
suddenly just
alive with so many papers right that
hadn't been vetted and does that mean
that there was a lot of dross
sure but that also mean that there was a
lot of stuff that we normally wouldn't
have been able to see because it would
have been vetted
out of existence but it actually needed
to be seen yes
also the reduction in quality control
actually served science beautifully it
was the demonstration
that those of us who aren't so fond of
peer review
were right because it was a very vibrant
period
i would just point out one other thing
um
this is a hard uh game to beat
um there's a part of me that actually
has a reaction people don't understand
where i quite like it
when my colleagues
attacked me for being stupid right
because
in so doing they are lodging the fact
that they and i disagree over something
and i
you know so for example there was this
case where i had put out a video
advocating for explorer modes as an
evolutionary phenomenon
and i got attacked uh by jerry coyne and
richard dawkins and stephen pinker
and neil schuben right and people
you know we're like am i feeling less
like yes exactly do you know what they
just did
they just announced that they disagree
with this idea which i am
quite certain will turn out to be right
now it may take a long time
but at the very least it's going to be
very hard to obscure
the fact that they didn't believe it
because they were all very vocal about
it
so um i would just say we should be
allowing people
uh to lodge these objections to the um
to the dominant school of thought and
then
if you turn out to be non-trivially
right if you turn out to be right for
the right reasons
and very far ahead of your time then the
point is actually well what else do you
know
that's what we should be looking for
yeah okay we gotta we gotta go a little
faster through these
um now finally we are going to get to
the first question from today
is the rise of social justice a
religious revolution that our cultural
adaptation
wait a minute the rise of social justice
a religious revolution
our cultural adaptation to prevent
religious war that is religious
no it's not it's not no our cultural
adaptation to prevent religious war
can't recognize or
solve because the standard conception of
a religion assumes metaphysical claims
is it the same for marxism generally so
when i try to read it again it's not or
but there's some punctuation missing
probably because of
character limits is the rise of social
justice of religious revolution
which our cultural adaptation to prevent
religious war
um as in which would advocate for
which would preclude religious pluralism
can't
recognize or solve because the standard
conception of a religion assumes
metaphysical claims and is that the same
for marxism generally so
you know broadly social justice has been
widely discussed by us i think first by
john mcwhorter
um certainly by james lindsay as um
actually fitting
all of the rubrics for religion um but
the question the person asked in the
question is saying maybe most people
can't recognize it because it doesn't
have the metaphysical thing
and is might that also be the same
explanation for why people don't
recognize
marxism as a religion so i think there's
a lot
to this yeah i think it's a little bit
too
mechanistic in the sense that i think
the elements that are described here are
correct which is to say there is a very
strong religious aspect to these claims
right they are immune to challenge
because for the same reason that
religious claims are immune to challenge
that's right man
the fact that you're challenging it says
there's something wrong with you right
um but
it is not exactly a religion right and
the absence of
metaphysical claims explicit
metaphysical claims
puts it in an adjacent category at best
well we need but i mean i think
i mean mcquarter has really written so
beautifully about this a number of times
but i and i suspect
i can't remember what he does exactly
but as a linguist i'm sure he gets
somewhere in this cat in this
in this territory that we basically okay
so religion is like one instantiation of
some bigger category so rather than say
like okay this thing is adjacent
maybe that's so but the venn diagram
needs the the larger categorical
description
of the thing that includes religion and
social justice and perhaps marxism
and a number of other things all of
which have these i don't know what it
would be 6 8
20 you know whatever um descriptors
well um i agree with that but i would
say
the larger category and i don't remember
what mcwhorter uses as the larger
category
the larger category i would use is
literally false metaphorically true
and remember literally false
metaphorically true is
about um advancing an evolutionary
agenda no i don't think that's right
literally false metaphorically true is
important and critical
and you we can approach those things and
say ah so i can see why kosher laws
and why it's not the story you tell but
why it's important and can be assessed
and agreed with or not from outside or
from inside whereas the the religion
part of this
which is its own ecosystem like a claim
that is literally false metaphorically
true is just a claim but this
this is we're talking about the whole
ecosystem so i don't think literally
false metaphorically true is the bigger
category
well i'm not sure i understand the
objection you just leveled my point
would be
these the people advancing these claims
are rapidly increasing in their power to
shape civilization
to their own ends yes that
the claims are nonsense right yes but
they are advancing in power and so i
would say that does
roughly meet the um the definition
now ultimately they will be unstable
but let's just put it this way literally
false metaphorically true
is a broad category that can be applied
to um
let's say scientific beliefs belief in
gravitational potential energy is such a
belief right
if you believe if you act as if you
believe it you can calculate all sorts
of things that you can't calculate
if you disbelieve it but there isn't any
evidence for it um
but so the distinction i'm making and i
think it's actually critical
is it's it's akin to it's analogous to
an individual versus population level
analysis
that a tenet of religion might be
literally
false metaphorically true much as a
tenet of a
scientific um worldview might be
literally false metaphorically true
um but the actual religion the actual
worldview
is the population level which is it is
not
just it has emergent properties that
include not just a collection of these
tenets but also some additional
structure
okay you're right under normal what
under normal circumstances the belief
structure
would accompany a lineage which is the
reason
that the ecosystem level analysis isn't
the right one because the evolutionary
entity actually isn't it yeah so i meant
to say that i'm going to back off the
use of the word ecosystem and go back to
individual versus population right both
of which are
both of which are evolutionary entities
except in this case the population
isn't an evolutionary entity which is
why i've argued it's unstable and will
come apart in the end in this case
social justice or
religion like social justice okay so
so you then are also taking issue with
like okay it's not
exactly religion there is something less
stable because of the lack of lineage oh
yeah
is it but i'm asking is that your is yes
because the internal dynamics in which
one lineage turns on the other will
ultimately tear the thing apart from the
inside guaranteed
right so um yeah
in any case the uh
the falseness of the claims are
paired with a strategy that is highly
successful at gaining
power this is temporary but that doesn't
rule it out
um and uh the difficulty in spotting it
the difficulty in spotting it probably
does have to do with the fact that it
isn't
explicitly metaphysical yeah i think
that's i think that's insightful
yeah yeah but i think the thing that in
the question that is hard for me to
accept is that our you know built-in
resistance
i don't know that we have a built-in
resistance the the built-in resistance
to the extent it exists at all
has to do with the fact that there are
you know to the extent you dispense
with a claim that is no longer
functional
you have an advantage and so you know in
this very short time window
that's not the case these people have
the advantage um and
and that's what's going on okay next
uh is just a comment i'm gonna read it
because
here it is shabbat shalom brett please
reach out to the mods of the facebook
group
it's at 2000 members and the mods need
your help thanks for the excellent
content
please reach out to yes okay what did
you think
i thought you said please reject and i
was like what the heck is going on all
right
please reach out to the mods all right
all right um next question i'm an
engineer at a large
oem oem original equipment manufacturer
all right both both the y chromosome
types in the room had that at the
tips of their tongues that was new old
stock
what's that it was new old stock nos oh
goodness
i'm an engineer at a large oem which
depends on federal contracts and which
is forcing crt on its employees myself
included
what can we do to expand the trump
administration's anti-crt memo to
include companies with contracts with
the federal government
i think you've just answered your own
question
which is the funding can be made
contingent i don't know what you can do
but uh to the extent so i mean
obviously um there are risks
to i mean in this case i would want that
right yeah i think i think this ideology
is so dangerous
um but once you establish
a way for the federal government to uh
decide what can
and cannot be taught or said um across
things that are beyond the scope of the
actual federal government
don't you we get at least into slippery
slope territory of
uh potential overreach ah i don't think
so i mean
the route for government abuse is there
yeah the point the point that
is so central here is that
look abuse is always a possibility right
abuse of power
but the the entire informal nature of
all of this
is taking the governmental protections
against
abuse and sidelining them so for example
when you
establish a um an administrative
position at a college
whose purpose is to ensure diversity
equity and inclusion
which i'm not going to do incidentally
thank you you're welcome but this
happened
while we were at evergreen yes it did
well we were at evergreen
affirmative action was illegal in the
state of washington
this was an affirmative action program
so that should have been prevented by
the laws that were already on the books
it at least
circumvented those laws because it would
have been inconceivable to hire somebody
who was not
intersectional into that position
likewise i would say these departments
right they are circumventing the
protections against discrimination and
the um so will there is there the
potential
for governmental abuse yes we've just
seen
some of this uh the supreme court
decision on
trans rights uh and the protection
um the supreme court just issued a
decision
bringing uh trans people
in on protections and plausibly the
decision might
force the inclusion of for example trans
women in
uh sports uh i i don't know i i i
it doesn't matter the point is it sounds
like something i should know about and i
can't speak to it because i just don't
know at this point
the potential for abuse exists but the
point is
at your university or at your
corporation
when people with power start forcing
other people to say stuff and teach
stuff and things like that
there's no mechanism to challenge it at
least at the governmental level there is
a process by which we can say
is it fair to bar this right we don't we
don't disagree on any of the particulars
here i'm just concerned
about desiring more federal input
into decisions in private corporations
uh i would say
the other way i would say that the only
prevention
of some
false belief system taking over and
forcing its way through your
institutions
is protections against that at the
governmental level where there's a
process to establish this is actually a
fact and that isn't
right yeah i mean there will there will
be for
any one of these there will be someone
on this on one side that says we
absolutely need this or else democracy
will fail and someone on the other side
who says we actually can't have this or
else democracy will fail and
um you know we we feel certain from
as many domains as we could possibly
have that this particular
critical race theory woke ideology etc
is
um is is actually an existential threat
at the societal level yep but
that doesn't mean that once you have
some power that has been
instantiated for this particular example
um that it can't be used badly elsewhere
i agree and this is the kind of thing
that
libertarians are constantly saying who
will watch the watchers but my sense is
um we're stuck with that because it's
better
than the alternative which is no process
at all yeah
um and so there we are okay
um would you agree that kendi and
d'angelo took a kernel of truth and grew
a very misshapen crop
perhaps people have racist impulses
which they resist say the reptilian
brain seeks a tribalism which higher
function must rebuke
um you're not suggesting appointing
candy
and deangelo the kernel of truth for one
thing they would be kernels of truth
i believe i know you're going to tell me
it's spelled differently
i would but i won't bother because you
already did it for me um
yeah there's there's a colonel yeah and
i i want to say no actually like
there are some
d'angelo i think correctly diagnoses her
own personal problem
and then yeah extrapolates to every
other person
who shares her skin color and that
extrapolation
is wrong right so
that kernel of truth in that case is
robin deangelo turns out to be a racist
like she just has racist thoughts
and uh she is embarrassed by them and
she's decided to make bank on that
embarrassment
candy seems to be and i have not
finished
the one book that i am willing to read
of his and i don't think i need to put
myself through any more of that but
i'm still not done with it um but
candy i'm not even sure like he has true
observations
about um past
and even current examples of racism
but um the the leap that he then makes
to anti-racism is
equality of outcome and everything else
is racist doesn't even connect
so there's not even like i don't i don't
think that
the examples of racism that are true
that are the kernels of truth
would grow into the crop that he makes
so it's just it's not even a
there's not even connection but i don't
i don't think so okay i mean what we're
disagreeing over then is the question
about the kernel of truth and the
continuity between that and the thing
that they ultimately arrive
that's that's my objection to to seeing
the
to to this framing for candy at any rate
and then for d'angelo it's well
yeah for her i see how she got there for
her but then she extrapolates and and
no you can't you can't claim that you
are everyone because you're not
right but the kernel of truth is that
there are you know these are both
numbskulls who have
kendi's no numbskull i think deangelo
actually probably just isn't very bright
but kendy's
clearly quite smart i'm not saying he's
not smart yeah i still think he's a
numbskull for
pulling this on us because i'd go with
it [ __ ]
all right fair enough um but the point
is
uh people like deangelo exist
yeah so her extrapolation to it's all of
us is clearly absurd
but the kernel of truth is yeah there's
some low-level
thing that exists in some fraction of
the population right
um and in candy's case you know
there there is a
activity against racism an active
activity against racism that is
warranted and i will use an example from
my own life
when we were teaching i used to be very
conscious
about the fact that if i was looking for
uh an example of a person engaged in a
behavior
and i just googled for somebody to put
together a lecture if i
googled you know love right or couple
i would just get a sea of white people
sure right and so i would
actively search for something that
didn't come out of that sea of white
people just so that my examples
not always but sometimes well it's not
that you never used white examples no
i attempted to equalize the thing so
that my
students did not have the sense of like
oh this lecture about humor and white
people
you know it's like in the case of love
or humor which are human universals
your examples should actually be
reflective of the background
demographics of humanity
right which turns out to be in that case
but that i mean this like
in the case of for instance software
engineers you don't have to make all of
your examples
you know one to one male to female
because actually right no that
background demographic is not going to
be a match
and that's not because patriarchy and it
turns out to be a diminishing returns
problem if you try to obligate yourself
to deliver
a set of lectures that has no racial
bias in it like you'll spend the rest of
your life trying to build it can't be
done because for one thing even if you
try to correct it through google google
you know
to the extent you use search terms you
know you know it becomes your full-time
job which is exactly what we're seeing
it becoming for many people
right and you know i should tell you i
talked to my students about this at some
point and they pointed out that there
were
um that if you googled things from
different places you've got different
racial biases
in the results you mean from different
like isps or yeah
from different nations they're used to
vpn oh so anyway you could
see the wheels turning inside of the
thing but
anyway the point is yeah if you if you
want to give a lecture on
the nature of humor i actually think
it's much better to find
a you know kung people laughing than it
is to find
you know in order in part to point out
the universality exactly because if
you're talking to a bunch of american
undergraduates they know that people in
manhattan can laugh
right and they don't necessarily
understand that it is universal and this
frankly is the cure
in part for racism right so i think the
important end growth of this is you do
want somebody in our position
to make a good faith effort to deliver
something that's maximally educational
and that means does not feed people's
inherent biases
about these concepts but do you want the
right
for people to wag their finger at you if
you do put a white person on the screen
they say
why'd you do that right you don't you
want everybody to
make a good faith effort to be properly
inclusive and you do not want some power
stricture
structure empowered to um to look over
your shoulder and
you know seek errors yep okay next one
is just a comment
there is no way to not feed the crazed
left all stories have forced conclusions
for them
if you can't talk then you fight they
won't allow us to talk to them
a fight is coming trump 2020 stays safe
guys
um i agree with some of this yeah i do
too
do not feed the crazed left and it's he
says there is no way
to not feed the crazed left well i think
what he's saying
is other than fight
and i agree that at some level one must
fight but that
it's not nuanced enough because there
are a great many people
who don't giving people an alternative
is important and so a lot of the people
who are espousing this stuff
superficially in order to keep
themselves safe are not actually
um consumed by it and uh reaching a
handout to those who can be
uh reached is both strategically smart
and ethically right but
yes the fight is coming clearly um
oh well we got to get through a few more
of these oh actually
sorry this is the second part of the
question from the same person
um like a child no
these two are two parts of one question
i lost where i was from it
thoughts on antifa black lives matter
and black bloc
using the same weaponized control the
narrative tools
learned from the mainstream media in
order to influence public opinion
it's now justified as a taste of your
own medicine argument in the defense of
their actions
it's like a child reanimating abusive
parental behavior
please speak to altering the child's
behavior while the parent is still
acting abusively
thank you both for being brave mature
intelligent adults
yeah yeah i i agree with this the taste
of your own medicine thing is
um i mean in fact you've chosen the
perfect
example right to the extent yeah uh
that somebody is abused and that
triggers abusive tendencies in them
that's understandable but who gets
abused it's not the people who abuse
them
it's so it's not a taste of your own
medicine it's inflicting it on another
generation of people
well and the way the way he ends um
before the the gratitude for which we
are
ourselves grateful please speak to
altering the child's behavior while the
parent is still acting abusively
and you know i think this is this is the
mess we're in
everywhere we turn that um trying to get
people to start acting honorably when
they can
easily point to and usually you know
people don't have the sort of ordered
thought processes to carefully point but
they're sort of thrashing about going
but
the thing that i'm objecting to is still
going on
how dare you expect me to stop and this
you know this is some of the rhetoric
that we're hearing
even from you know the the like antifa
black lives matter black bloc um and
even even if some of their examples
aren't true
and the narrative isn't what they say it
is and you know all of this
are they reacting to something real have
they been handed a
bad deal has a whole generation of
americans been handed a deal that
doesn't look like the one
that people used to get handed yeah yeah
they have and that doesn't it's not
necessarily incumbent on them to
understand
everything that they have had to uh
contend with in part because their
parents
and the drugs they were given and the
schools they went to and the screens
they were sat in front of
broke them sufficiently that they don't
have an ability in some
to some degree to actually diagnose
themselves
yep i agree um for another time we
should talk about
uh a broader view of this
where meritocracy coupled with
a brutal lack of a safety net results in
a certain number of people
who don't have any reason to defend a
meritocratic system because they will be
on the losing end of it
so yes they were these people were
miseducated and
betrayed by a medical system that
drugged them in all of that
but it should not be surprising that
those who don't see themselves as
winning in a meritocratic system attack
it
yeah that's right
ignoring facts that conflict with a
desire to truth is widespread
what's the solution you see it with ted
wheeler
but also at boeing management with 737
max
do you know this example trying to
remember it i don't know the example
at all i was aware of it but i can't
resurrect it
um but you know what's the solution to
ignoring facts that conflict with the
desired truth
well the solution is
the alignment of incentives right the
fact is a
system that's right that causes you to
pay the price for ignoring facts that
you
had at your disposal is a good one and
so you know just to take one example
red teams that have an incentive to find
the weakness in the structure you have
built
incentivize you not to build a weak
structure so this is a term of art
in engineering or something yeah i think
it's mostly in computer security
okay but it can be in anything right you
have a red team that is
going to try to exploit your security
for your building right
can you get in you make it a game where
they win if they get in and then you
find out if you're
if you've got a flaw and red
you know we need intellectual red teams
too this is why i say
you should never allow one school of
thought to take over a field
at the very least you need the next best
school of thought there to keep them
honest otherwise they're all going to go
crazy which they do
that's the royal opposition the loyal
opposition right yeah
um our declawed not by me cat
sharpened her claws on a cardboard edge
why
instinct have it unlikely i haven't seen
it before
um yeah yeah i think
i mean the idea that you can declaw cats
is new and i
think i hope it's new and don't do it
like really horrifying and i appreciate
the person asking the question says it
wasn't by
her um but um yeah i think
uh it basically is moving it's it's
both honing the the nails the claws and
and getting the muscles working
well uh i've always imagined that it has
something to do with causing the claw
to curve that basically there's like um
what would you it'd be like um the
process by which plants bend towards the
light
that actually in this case attention
putting pressure um
but in any case why does a cat do it if
it doesn't have claws well presumably
there's something wired in where the cat
experiments with this behavior and
discovers oh that feels really good
and it feels good because when they do
have claws it helps them you know maybe
it's get the right curve maybe it may be
i don't know maybe claws are a little
bit like teeth and they're actually sort
of connected by ligaments such that you
know getting the right pressure on them
makes them
stronger and aligned right whether or
not they're shaped right but
whatever it does for them it does
something that selection wants to
um encourage more of and so it feels
good and so the feels good
uh that feels good circuit persists even
when the claws don't yep
i can see the cat in your lap he
disbelieves all of this
yes it's wrong he just wants more cream
yeah
okay uh do short-lived species such as
mice
adapt better to changing circumstances
because of greater generational turnover
if so is there any evolutionary
advantage to being a very long-lived
species
that's why there are no long-lived
species you heard it here first
[Laughter]
um this is so this is a great question
you're not going to see where it's going
but
here's the thing yes your instinct is
right
um our mammalian immune system
provides a very interesting example that
more or less
proves your point it's the exception
that proves the rule in the correct
version of
the use of that phrase your immune
system
evolves on an hourly basis
if you are challenged by a pathogen you
actually actually have
evolution taking place in the
specific immunity that is to say the
cells that respond to the pathogen
which is how you ultimately defeat it so
in a sense
your pathogen is a very short-lived
species that evolves very rapidly to
parasitize you
you are a very long-lived species which
makes you a sitting target
right in order to be a sitting target
and persist for a long life
you have a subsystem of you that evolves
on the same
scale as the pathogen so that you can
beat it
right because basically you have
microbes that are you
that are evolving to counteract other
microbes and viruses and things
so yes you would be probably unable to
live a long
life as an animal a plant can do this in
a different way
basically by uh you know a plant can
drop a limb and not die because it plant
is not composed of vital organs in the
same way
so an animal in order to
not die of being a sitting target in a
world of pathogens
has a subsystem that evolves on the same
time scale
proving your point great okay we'll do
one more here
um and then go on to super chat from
this hour
i will say that there's another question
here
advising you to reach out to the mods of
the facebook group so for a different
person
so something is going on there dangerous
question
how is encouraging medical transition
for trans people
any different from encouraging breast
implants etc for women with body
dysmorphia
good faith reason the former is okay but
not the latter
question mark um
this is a tough one i would say that
there's a distinction
i have a sense that the body dysmorphia
in uh straight
women presumably you mean non-trans
women the women who are getting breast
implants because of body dysmorphia
i believe are in large measure
responding
to a advertising and media apparatus
that is making them
insecure about something they needn't be
insecure about because
that enriches those who are making them
insecure and so
we are creating a pathology
and they are remedying that pathology
with an
augmentation and at some level the right
answer to that is not the augmentation
it's the um refiguring thing so that
making other people insecure is not a
profitable business model
yeah i mean this is it will the borders
of the categories will always be hard to
know
exactly where they are always but
with regard to women getting plastic
surgery of any sort to
better fit their you know the beauty
norms that they perceive
as the ones that they want to better fit
um is
largely market driven and advertising
driven
and some of what is going on
with with trans and you know the the the
many the orders of magnitude rise in the
number of for instance teenage girls who
are declaring themselves trans
would appear also to be some combination
of
um social contagion and encouragement
from larger society who are jumping on
the bandwagon
for reasons that we won't go into right
now but but
can and probably will elsewhere um so
those two kinds of um desire to
to change your body i think are actually
very similar whereas
they're you know trans is real and there
are
cases where people really do have such
a mismatch in their heads between what
they feel themselves to be
and what they were born as uh and
i you know i i see i i think it is
an honorable and um and
fair thing to do as a society to allow
such people
um to to have a match between their
their brains and their bodies but um it
is a tiny
minority of humans and is also i would
say a tiny minority of people who are
currently
um describing themselves as trans yeah i
would say we also
don't have a tremendous amount of
information on
you know as you say trans is real
and until recently surgical
interventions and
pharmaceutical interventions would have
been impossible right and many cultures
make allowances
for trans people that legitimize them
in their original form and i guess the
question is are we doing
people a greater service by
experimenting
with surgery and pharmaceuticals or
would we be better off just figuring out
you know how to you know bring them
fully into the protections and
understanding of society
right now that would be that would be
the more honorable move i'm sure of it
um okay next question
from this hour the dictionary has
changed the definition of female and
male to include gender identity
how can we defend against this type of
newspeak
so i i'll bet it has i'd le i'd love a
reference i'd love to know which
dictionary we're talking about
although i believe at least some
dictionaries
have begun to i know a couple months ago
there was a move to
change the definition of racism in
webster's i believe and webster said
sure
why not can't see what's gonna happen
downstream of this decision
um how can we defend against this type
of newspeak
and i think i think we're trying to do
it
and we're trying in part it's not most
of what we're doing
but in part by having conversations
between us that are unscripted and real
and the kinds of conversations that we
have at least sometimes we're not on
camera
to give to you watching and listening
the some of the language
that allows that will allow you to push
back in conversation
i don't know how what the pushback
against the dictionary changing
will look like but those changes happen
because there is a widespread acceptance
and the widespread acceptance happens
because in conversation
people who disagree are quiet and people
who disagree
um being quiet is in part because
they're scared but it's also in part
because
they're not really sure they know it
doesn't feel right wait male and female
are our biological sex this is real
but they don't have the certainty of
their own footing
to defend themselves against the frankly
the crazy that comes at them
so part of what we're trying to do i
think we haven't ever talked about this
but is to
is to share a language that other people
can use
um to discuss these things with people
when when it comes up
yep um i would say there is an argument
that the market
should solve the dictionary thing and
the problem is that
those who are fighting to poison
language
are trying to stigmatize
entities that attempt to give you higher
quality definitions
yep so we have to figure out how to
protect those entities
but i would just add one other thing
that i think we are doing
and i think this was something that we
did a lot
as professors was demonstrating that
what we are
saying is part of a world view that if
you just kind of let it
interact makes sense in other words you
could come up with some of the things
that we claim are true
and they could just exist in isolation
but if you tried to have a conversation
based on those premises it would fall
apart
on the other hand what we're talking
about is part of a deep
toolkit of understanding that's well
tested and the question is well all
right how comfortable would you be
at their table if you were trans could
you sit at their table and listen to
this conversations you were trans and
the fact is we've had lots of trans
students and interacted with them
very easily and comfortably and so the
point is
when extrapolated from this worldview
holds up
in light of true variation yeah right
which is
an important thing to demonstrate
next question heather could you come
could you come please share some of your
exercises for teaching math to children
thanks a lot you're both heroes be
blessed
um
yeah i don't um i'd be happy to share
some of how i have taught math and i
have
um you know the the the work that i've
mostly when i have taught math it's been
to undergraduates which are usually not
the people
i think of when people say children but
um of course there's an argument to be
made there
um
let me think i have to think on how to
answer this question and probably it
warrants just having something written
out and shared
but um one thing that is absolutely true
is just
pointing out the math and daily life and
pointing out its
its power and beauty everywhere and so
um
you know when when we're going somewhere
with with the children
um talking about how far we're going and
whether or not how far
actually you know that the number of
miles on a bike
actually is a full measure of how hard
it is and what that means
what you know number of miles doesn't
necessarily track to
to how difficult so what other things
might you measure what other things
might you be
be counting and keeping track of um and
you know this is easy to do in the
kitchen where um if you take a recipe
that is
using sort of an american standard of
for instance weight or
rather volume and you want to um use
weight
um you or and you want to double it you
know you
say the kid okay this calls for two cups
of flour and there's five ounces of
flour in a cup and we're going to double
the recipe how many ounces of flour do
we need
and you just start making it
backgrounded
like you just start
i am grateful to have never heard from
either of our children
what use will math be to me i cannot
imagine ever uttering those words myself
and i would have felt quite a failure if
either of them had ever said that not to
say that they either of them enjoyed
everything that i did to them or
every time i threw math at them but um
just making it part of the background
and part of the fun is is a big way to
do it
um i would just add something else that
i know your dad did with you and you now
do with our kids which is
there's kind of an understanding that
the purpose of math is not to get to the
answer so you can stop doing it
right so the fact that you can get to
the answer
doesn't really mean anything if you
don't know how it was that it worked
that you got there
and so um going through some other way
to get there in order that you can see
um what the process meant and why is the
key to understanding it and treating it
other than
a take your medicine kind of endeavor
yeah
and this is i mean this is part of the
you know a it's also about the journey
but also the journey is fun the journey
isn't a slog
and i guess i would just say one other
thing i am still
stunned by uh my own experience in
college with calculus
right i had calculus from two different
teachers
and one of them who was not well liked i
thought was absolutely phenomenal
because
at the board he just took a joy in
illustrating why things were functioned
the way they did and showing us how to
do things and
it totally worked for me and the other
one who was pretty well liked
was very mechanical and it was just very
hard
to care right because it was just simply
a matter of here's how you do that
right right and recipe yeah right so
anyway
it's all about incentives and to the
extent that the person up there is
motivated by the right stuff and can
convey the joy of
doing these things uh properly that's
the hardest part
right the math itself isn't that hard
it's the
you know getting you oriented to it
correctly and knowing that you want to
go through it because
what you get at the other side is
rewarding that's the
important part yeah and that's that's
right and i do i mean i do remember
um bringing math homework home when i
was a kid
and having my dad look at how i was
being told to do things in the you know
late 70s
and i'm just oh for god's sake no like
this you're
you're not going to memorize a bunch of
stuff you know
there's there will be no way that at the
end of doing this you will know
you will understand the the beauty and
the truth of the math you will only know
how to do this current thing that is
fashionable which frankly math isn't
about fashion sorry
no yeah he he was shaking his head
analog back before it had become an
online thing
yeah yeah he was okay i was gonna say
something else but you just
wow you just put that right in there i
don't remember what it was okay
uh what is the best star trek series and
why is it deep space nine
it says holly math nerd deep space nine
is the one in the space station where
nothing ever happens why would that be
the best
so we have to admit that um we we
enjoy star trek but haven't watched much
of it uh
and i don't honestly remember i don't
know
i don't have an opinion in the space
station where nothing ever happens so
well but i just but do you have an
answer to the first part of the question
i mean obviously
start correct the best series why is the
best star trek
what is the best star trek series and
why is it deep space nine
well i couldn't even name them all i
mean i couldn't even name
more than two honestly i think holly
is um clear this is a back door to
meditation
that the fact that nothing happens in
deep space nine makes it more
contemplative
this is a wink to the buddhists there
you go yeah yeah
okay good one holly um yeah no
i i can't imagine what you're thinking
actually but
okay and i just i don't know enough we
should do some yeah we should
probably watch some more star trek i'm
not watching deep space nine
wow okay at my university student org
is pressuring faculty to have mandatory
anti-racism courses and training
they are surprisingly effective at
organizing and lobbying how can regular
people push back
so you don't say sam jam uh author of
this question if you are a student or
faculty and the answer it's hard either
way for sure
but the answer is somewhat different
depending on which position you're in
what
i'm just thinking that you know
literature has everything to teach us
about this and there's this
i unfortunately was not prepared for
this question but in catch-22
um there is a scene in which
um the pilots are being
instructed in some way and one of them
causes havoc
by asking some question like when is
now why is right and where are the
snowdens of yesteryear
so you might take that kind of approach
in seriousness you might take the
approach of
asking good-natured but impossible to
field
questions and then letting the thing
collapse of its own accord
i think if i okay but you know what like
you you are the master of this and it's
really hard for the rest of us to either
it's one of two things like to come up
with the thing
that will that will effectively be the
stick and the gears
right yeah um in real time or if you
come up with it like
imagining saying it with a straight face
like just like getting it out of your
mouth like i i've been in that position
i've learned enough from you in this
regard
that i can sometimes come up with
exactly the thing i might say then like
i'm going to burst out laughing like
there's no way i can do this in the
street
so you really you have to hone you got
to scale it and you got it
but but it's worth honing especially if
you're going to be subjected to this
nonsense so
um yeah yeah see if you can't perfect it
and just you what you want to just
lob the question that causes the thing
to reveal itself
right there's to the extent that you can
learn that you will find it is a
delightful exercise
yeah um and i haven't i haven't gotten
there yet but i
um i think the last chapter of helen
plecos and james lindsay's book cynical
theories
um actually gets at some things that
they are saying
you can you can do to push back against
this um and so i
i said i haven't haven't gotten there in
the book yet but i imagine that it's got
some
some very good advice and i got there
from
having just listened to megan dom's
latest podcast which is a conversation
with helen
plecos and it's it's quite good so even
just that just listening to that hour of
conversation between
megan and helen on megan's new podcast
which is called the unspeakable
i think the unspeakable podcast um
is is quite good and um
she has one particular piece of advice
that i can't remember but maybe it'll
come to me as we're answering other
questions
okay to what extent is political
ideology hereditary
what evolutionary advantages are there
to different proto-political ideologies
what evil evolutionary advantages are
there to
different proto-political ideologies so
here's the problem every time
you raise the question of heredity or
hereditary
or heritability you run into the same
predicament
which is that these words have a meaning
in common parlance that has a
relationship
to their technical meaning but the
relationship is
not straightforward
so to what extent is it heritable do you
mean genetically because heritable
is a genetic phenomenon um
technically it shouldn't be because
there are multiple pathways
for heredity and to the extent that you
include something like cultural heredity
then it is highly heritable the
household you grew up in has a lot to
say about
what you end up thinking though probably
not at all
transmitted on a genetic pathway and
i would say if i can just cite eric here
for a second
long time ago eric and i were talking
about
the problem of these wrong beliefs that
are very
powerful politically powerful and he
said
truth is the second best strategy which
is one of the
smartest things anybody's ever said to
me and the meaning
was instantly clear in the context of
our conversation what it means
is some of us default to truth as a
a mechanism for getting through the
world right it doesn't mean we're right
but it means that we
seek to be right because that provides
you um with
some power but it's not the best route
to power
at all the best route to power is
affiliation
with some thing and that thing can be
saying totally wrong stuff
but if it's powerful it will carry you
along with it
and so what is the evolutionary
advantage to different proto-political
ideologies
some of those political ideologies may
be inventing something marvelous in
other words the american experiment
is really about creating opportunity
that is broadly distributed
and that does not pay attention to what
lineage you come from that's a great
idea
and it was very powerful and maybe it
will be again
so signing up for that political
ideology
is a noble thing to do on the other hand
signing up for woke ideology that's
going to tear that all down in order to
get some stuff
is a terrible idea but it's powerful and
so the advantage
is power but the question is what is the
basis of the power is the power
derived honorably because the system
discovers good stuff and distributes it
or is the power derived falsely by
stealing stuff and
corralling well-being for example
good have you heard of parker
crutchfield's morality pill to make
people complacent to lockdown measures
suggested adding it to water supplies
thoughts
i don't um i'm not sure i heard about
one
that was microdosing with psilocybin i
don't know if this is that
um either
either way either this is that or this
is something else uh
adding adding stuff to water supply
seems a really really dangerous game
another time we can talk about fluoride
and why that
itself was likely a very dangerous game
um but the idea of adding
the idea of drugging the population
against their will
not so much no real really terrible idea
now if this is the same thing that i'm
thinking of which is
a suggestion suggesting basically people
micro dosing on something like
psilocybin uh
in order to deal with uh justified
anxiety from the state of the world
uh there are potentially large
advantages to that but it has to be on
an opt-in basis
yeah has to be i would agree
brett your idea of a place advertising
its hospitality
to those escaping the devolving west
coast is good what is stopping existing
or new educational institutions from
doing the same
to those escaping our broken academy oh
my god yeah i mean we've talked about
this
so much and i the
even the university of chicago yep even
the university of chicago
with its um statement of the chicago
statement of principles i can't remember
what it's called now um
uh is has begun to cave to some of this
woke ideology and it just seems so
obvious that there are so
many would-be college students out there
and so many parents
would be college students out there who
are interested in paying tuition
to a school that isn't woke that would
be flocking to a school that was pushing
back against this
that maybe if you were the 200th
institution
to declare yourself and actually follow
through
on not being woke um that you wouldn't
attract a flood of students but i think
even if you were the 200th
institution to do that you would
certainly if you were in the first ten
like why doesn't any one of the number
of now
struggling because of covid as if they
weren't struggling enough already
liberal arts colleges or even r1
universities
make a stand and be firm about it and i
think then
watch the applications and then tuition
dollars pour in
yeah so the fact that this strategy
seems like it would be such a slam dunk
that you know any college president who
figured out how to pull it off would be
heralded as a genius and a great hero of
the institution and all that and yet
they don't
tells you something about the horizontal
nature of this revolution
the point is inside of each institution
there is enough firepower
to drive out or destroy anybody who
tries it
so every institution goes over the edge
rather than it's spreading from the top
of institutional institution it's
spreading horizontally within them
and yeah i guess i should just add that
that's not a good thing
oh i thought you were advocating for it
no no no no quite the opposite okay no
i guess we're on the same page now you
are an hour and 12 minutes
okay uh let's do four more
ibram x kendi is giving a zoom
presentation at my university this week
what should i ask him i want to be
respectful but push back on kafka traps
so again it's different if you're a
student a faculty
or admin if you're a student
in this case i would say you actually
have a little bit more
uh freedom a little bit more leverage uh
to be a little bit pushier with them if
you're faculty or admin you might end up
behind the scenes getting metaphorically
beaten up for pushing back on
the sage of the day um
well i would i would ask him and mind
you i have not read his book but
um i would ask him whether or not
there was an end point how you would
know when you reached it and if there is
no end point how this isn't
simply even if we follow his
prescription going to result in an
equally
unfair terrible unstable and dangerous
situation on the far end of it
yeah i guess actually i'm remembering
now what helen plucker has said in this
conversation with megan dom
and it has to do with saying you know
i don't know the politics of the person
asking but helen is speaking um as a as
a liberal
and she says you know um
the i don't know what we should call
them but in this case
candy speaking for anti-racism a term
that he is defined
um don't speak for
all of us on the left in any way and so
as a
if you're a liberal you could do what
helen suggests and say
look um i am also
you know grateful for all of the many uh
wins that liberalism experienced in the
20th century
um you know for in for civil rights and
for women's rights and disability rights
and you know
freedom of religion including not having
any religion all of this
uh and i have a very
different understanding of how best to
continue to make progress
and that different understanding does
not make me the enemy
and if you think that it does then and
this is
this i don't think helen says this but
this is sort of where i would take it
if you think that my different
understanding of how we might get to
what you
say you would claim our shared goals
then i would suggest that maybe the
goals that you have are not the ones
that you say they are
nice nice that's really good uh the next
one merely says meow
i've still got the kitty in my lap so uh
we'll do three more after that because
that was an easy one
um what's your opinion on the idea that
the struggles and adversity of
adventuring out of africa in part makes
up the disparity of iq differences
well the premise is not one that we are
going to agree with
um but even if you accepted the premise
i would say it misunderstands what
africa is
africa is not a little plot of land uh
in which things are easy going
and uh you have to you have to leave it
before things get difficult
africa is a giant continent with many
many different types of ecosystems
and uh and you know darwin's hostile
forces live
in all of its forms uh in africa as well
so
um the idea that moving
between continents is the thing that
makes you smart isn't a very sappy
argument yeah um yeah i just think
there's nothing
nothing to it yeah and i mean really
like if if that were true
you would predict that the people who
ended up in tierdo fuego would be the
smartest of all because they traveled
the farthest across the most domain
changes right
and right okay uh penultimate question
elysium health a startup with phds
claims that their nad plus supplements
activates suturins
and promote quote cellular health and
healthy aging
is this bs unverified or supported by
science
um sure sounds like bs to me yeah i feel
like i've heard of these people and i
can't
i don't i don't i can't pull up more
than i feel like i've heard of these
people
um at the moment without looking it up
but yeah it sounds like bs
uh and um so i i think the thing the
the key thing is this if you're
deficient in something it can cause
ill health if you've got some pathway
and up regulating it makes you
more healthy why isn't it being
upregulated right
so there can be answers to this question
but in general the idea that you have
read some paper in which some pathway is
involved in some healthy thing
and some corporation decides it's going
to trigger that pathway and then say aha
we've found the key to more health it
just never pans out in terms of
the data even if they got good graphics
though well a really good graphics skill
kind of a long way yeah yeah and a good
brand name yeah
um so anyway i think you know there's a
smell test here and there are loopholes
right there are things about us that are
rigged sub-optimally because of some
environment we came from my go-to
example would be
we are rigged very stupidly for
cold when we go into the cold our
capillaries shut down
in order to protect our core and
preserve heat because our ancestors
didn't have enough food
whereas we could just we could up
ratchet the
circulation to the extremities we could
pump heat into them and then you could
eat more at dinner and
you'd be great but um but we don't do it
and so we risk frostbite and we become
inept and all of these things in the
cold that are needless
yeah for the modern overfed human it
would be win-win
you know you don't experience the cold
and you get to eat more without getting
fat right and in fact if we could turn
down our discomfort at being in the cold
it's the
go-to way to burn extra calories but the
problem
is you're wired not to do it because
your ancestors didn't have enough food
and so the point is spending energy
keeping yourself
warm is something you're wired to avoid
at all costs it's like
physiological laziness but it i mean
that's what it is yep
physiological laziness so anyway there
are places where there's a loophole that
you know if we could figure out how to
turn down our sensitivity to cold
and upregulate our circulation in light
of cold rather than
bring it to the core that'd be great um
in general these things are hard to do
right for the same reason it's hard to
do things like turn down appetite by
interfering with the
uh the chemical pathways involved um
but anyway there are there are
possibilities but in general these
things are nonsense
yep okay the next two are also comments
and then we'll get to one last question
before we
stop for the day uh just enjoying the
discussion want to donate
i'll formulate questions at some point i
have many love the pod
thank you hello and thank you both for
the fantastic work that you do i'm a
professional artist and would love to
assist with unity 2020 and your work in
some way much love to you both
i don't know if you have uh like a
email to se to suggest uh to the artist
who would be interested in
uh come sign up and uh
there's an onboarding process and we can
put you in touch with
our slack team that makes art
anyway it's a good thing to do great
okay one last question
yeah one last question for today ooh
at a considerable donation thank you
uh i turned to the outdoors during these
times but i'm also drawn more and more
to pornography and alcohol
what advice do you have to lessen my
consumption of these
it's not an addiction but it may be
becoming a habit i don't like it but
oddly hard to stop
these activities seem to creep up that's
that's a
terrific and terrifically worded
question as well and i appreciate your
distinction between addiction and habit
um habits are things we should all um
enable ourselves to form
when they are good and to try to stop
when they are bad but at what point
do they become addictions you had
something
well um i would say one thing that
you know we talked a little bit about
addiction and our broken model of it
on a past livestream one thing is better
options are
the key to avoiding addiction all right
so to the extent that you have more
entertaining things to do
you will tend not to default to the
stuff that you feel is destructive
in the case of of porn it's probably i
mean
you don't say enough about uh what your
relationship status is to know but
um to the extent that it scratches an
itch that
um if you had to work harder by
interacting with people um
to scratch the same itch you would end
up more rewarded because you would be
interacting with them
uh in a way that you know had a proper
challenge to it and all
um during lockdown if you don't have a
relationship um
it it might be very hard to know
how to proceed yep right i think
the thing i don't know if i've said this
anywhere yet but the thing about
porn is that it gets in the way
it is a consumer solution to
uh a
ability to generate fantasy internally
and so at some level you're denying
yourself something
and exposing yourself to the hazard of
what the market wants you to be
fantasizing about
and you'd be far better off to just say
uh you know this is blocking some a
cognitively productive activity i know
it's a weird thing to say about it
no but i mean you're making an argument
that is sounds
superficially similar to a familiar
argument but it's actually quite
different so
the the the argument that many people
will have heard a lot of places is that
uh you end up seeing this sort of menu
of options that are actually
mostly not at least for women what women
want to be engaging in but this is now
what's in
men's heads for instance about what it
is that they
they think is good sexual activity looks
like
um and you are saying not just does it
put
these um wrong things on a menu um
but it actually having a menu at all
having being handed a menu makes it less
easy and
less easy for you to create your own
sexual life and explore whatever your
own sexual fantasies might be
such that you actually may live an
impoverished
you know sexually impoverished fantasy
and actual sexual life forever after
because you thought from the beginning
that it was about a menu that it was
about someone handing you something that
this was
that sexuality was about market forces
that you know narrative was about market
forces in the case of you know a
slightly slightly related concept and
um yeah i mean i think that's i think
that's apt
i think it's good i want to add two
things to it one you had an
excellent piece come out in aerial
magazine this week
on pornography and well it's also about
lizards
and about lizards i mean of course the
two things like hand and glove
yeah um but sex love and sexual autism
in area
yep the other thing that i would say is
if we're comparing your internally
generated
sexual fantasy with porn right
here's something we can say for sure
porn
is a market phenomenon as a market
phenomenon
different producers are driven to
compete with each other in a market
saturated with stuff
are they delivering the ideal thing they
can't because if they deliver the ideal
thing what separates them from everybody
else so what they're delivering
is an increasingly extreme view of sex
and sexuality in order to get attention
you have to push
the envelope in order to stand out and
so what we know
is that porn has pushed the envelope way
the hell out into crazy directions that
you
wouldn't think to desire if they weren't
being
pushed at you as normal and so the
question is do you want to open
your sexual life to this
market force that pushes in the
direction of extreme
or would you rather figure out what you
actually want right
these are two um very different views
and basically
i think porn's hurting you so
stop it right the internally
endogenously
generated stuff is natural
and therefore your tendency
towards this that or the other is much
more likely to be healthy for you
so i agree with you but alcohol is also
hurting you
and we both drink alcohol we both are
probably drinking more alcohol than is
optimal for us probably any alcohol well
in our defense
it is 20 20. well but this i mean this
this is the question right
and um you know just to read it again i
think this is where we're going to stop
and
um but you know i turned to the outdoors
i imagine this is a man
he says during these times but i'm also
drawn more and more to pornography and
alcohol what advice do you have to
lessen my consumption of these we've
already spent time talking about porn
but with regard to alcohol he says it's
not an addiction
but it may be becoming a habit i don't
like it but it's oddly hard to stop
these activities seem to creep up
i feel very much this way about about
alcohol
actually um and you know the fact that
the person asking the question begins
when i turn to the outdoors you know i
felt
i am feeling the end of summer coming
and i was lucky enough to be able to
have the time
to get up early this morning and strap a
paddleboard on the top of the car and go
out to the willamette and spend an hour
on the water that
changed my outlook on the day until i
got back on the internet
but certainly if you can do that
do that not that particularly
necessarily but they're you know they're
already it was pretty early and there
were already so many people out there
families
um with kids fishing fishermen
people in kayaks not too many at that
time
people with jet skis and such um
and it really is healing but also
figure out what else you do
to feel your best and most complete self
you know do do you
create do you discover do you
heal other people what what is it
that is your truest and best self
and can you either do more of that or
expand your ability to do it you know
hone your skills
so you know it was sort of it became a
trope
early in covet lockdowns that everyone
was baking sourdough bread
and because of your gluten sensitivity
that's not something that i ended up
doing i probably
would have if we had all been able to
eat sourdough bread
but you know if if you live with other
people
and enjoy making things for them
you know cooking cooking for and with
other people
uh making art writing words and sharing
them with other people
making you know making things out of
wood if you have access to it wood or
metal or
you know anything just there there are
so many
ways i think that you can expand what it
is that you were finding value in
and it probably won't
completely replace alcohol and maybe not
porn although i would
i would advocate that that you should
try to completely replace the porn
um but it will probably lessen the pull
on you you will probably feel less than
need
at some point every day yeah i could
really go for a drink right now
all right two things to add yeah one i
saw an interesting where was it reddit
or something
um expose or maybe it was the response
to one of these ask reddit questions
about the amount of exploitation
of young people uh involved
in the porn industry um
so it's hurting people right so the
basic answer is look if it's hurting
people that's probably incentive enough
not to participate right because by
by consuming it you are driving
that harm to continue and you have an
alternative on the
um other front the alcohol front it's
great if you can take
days off also if you're not going to
take days off
less is better and here's an a solution
based on your
scenario here a
i can't drink beer anymore uh because of
the gluten thing but um
pint of cider or a pint of beer followed
by a bike ride
it's really in some ways kind of ideal
maybe not in heavy traffic
right well but you wouldn't want to be
biking heavy traffic anyway so anyway
consider instead of having two or three
pints have one pint and go for a ride
and see if it doesn't uh
get you there with half the consumption
yeah well i mean it's
it's also true for alcohol like almost
all drugs
um that taking a break makes the effects
when you go back to it um
more interesting and powerful anyway so
you know it's been years since we've
done this but for many years
i would i started and and and you
decided to adopt as well a habit of
saying okay every month
every month is going to be at least one
a week with no alcohol at all and
you know no drinking more than what was
it two days in a row or some two days or
three days in a row i don't remember
exactly what the rules were but it just
you know it keeps you keeps you honest
and it also means that when you go back
to it you'll actually feel it more
and you enjoy it more and you know what
are you doing it if if you're only doing
it to numb the pain
uh then there are there are bigger
issues and probably hopefully
uh for for someone in enough control um
to write this question
there are some better ways to um to find
to
get rid of some of the pain yep think of
it as tantric drinking
okay
all right um i think with that we have
reached the end of the q and a section
reached the end of something
yep that we did all right cool oh yes
and the dog has reached the end of the
something with us
so is there anything else we need to
announce nope uh consider joining us on
our patreons for
access to private q a uh once a month
online
access to the discord server on either
of them access to brett's
monthly conversations with a small group
of people the next one is tomorrow
tomorrow i will uh send out another
invite in case anybody signs up between
now and tomorrow to make sure
that you get the link and um
yeah we will probably be back this
tuesday but
um we'll definitely be back at some
point soon
all right be well
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you